als das problem ist hier das augustinus
sagt wir haben ein problem was nicht was
die gegenwart angelangt sollen was die
vergangenheit was die zukunft anbelangt
also sie ähneln sich noch wir hatten
zwei modelle hier an die tafel gemalt
einmal ist ist die zeit so zu verstehen
dass sie auf uns zukommt wie ihr auch
der begriff der zukunft sagt als wir
ruhe mehr oder weniger ich mal dahin
das ist es jetzt und die zukunft kommt
auf uns zu und fährt gewissermaßen
durchzieht durch uns hindurch wie es den
fix nach einem verständnis der zeit und
die zukunft wie gesagt die zeit kommt
auf uns zu läuft durch uns hindurch und
endet in der vergangenheit und läuft
dort weiter bis ins unendliche zurück
das ist eine vorstellung die andere
vorstellung ist die dass wir in der zeit
voran schreibt also dass diese six dass
das selbst bewegt ist also das nicht wir
als der gegenwart ruhen sein dass die
gegenwart weiter nach vorne schiebt die
zukunft hinein
sie sehen jetzt endlich kommt aufs selbe
hinaus überlegen sie sich mal dieses
beispiel die sitzen sie sind befinden
sich im bahnhof sitzen in einem zug und
plötzlich tut sich etwas und sie denken
moment jetzt fahre ich nach vorne jetzt
feder zog los und dann merken sie
plötzlich hoffnung ist nicht so sondern
der neben zug der fährt in die andere
richtung hätte ist die relativität und
genauso ist es mit der zeit ja auch sie
können sich das so vorstellen dass die
zukunft auf sie zukommt sie können sich
aber genauso wie in diesem beispiel am
bahnhof genauso denken dass sie nach
vorne fahren derzeit das können sie
jetzt prima partie erstmal gar nicht so
sehr unterscheiden aber wir wollen diese
diese diese zwei möglichkeiten immer vor
augen halten dass man als er sich zeit
auf diese diese weisen denken kann und
wie denkt sich jetzt augustinus
rückfragen sie welches modell hat
vertreter wir können einmal dieses zu
wir können einmal diese passivität
modell vielleicht dass eine nennen also
wenn wir in der gegenwart fixiert sind
der vielleicht das passivität modell das
wir sagen objekt derzeit erfahrung sieht
oder objekt derzeit richtung sind die
zeit läuft durch uns hindurch andere
möglichkeit könnte man vielleicht
das bewegungs modell nennen also das
ruhende modell wäre dass sie das andere
wäre das bewegende modell wo sich die
gegenwart ihnen immer weiter nach vorne
schieben derzeit welches modell vertritt
augustinus was würde ich sagen
ist eigentlich rechtlich klar in seinen
texten zu sehen
das war genau also er vertritt dieses
erste modell beruhen der hund
anführungsstrichen bewegte bewegte
gegenwart das sind so zwei vorständen
und wie ich versucht hatte ihn zu
illustrieren mit diesem bahnhofs
beispiel mit dem zug beispiel sie können
es erstmal gar nicht voneinander
unterscheiden es läuft auch selbe hinaus
das kann sein sie bewegen sich oder die
zeit bewegt sind
das nur mal so als eine
grundorientierung und jetzt bleibt noch
eine frage offen nämlich die letzte
frage
wie die zeit genau mit dem subjekt
zusammenhängt also dieses dieser x.de
gegenwart ist natürlich auch mit dem
subjekt derzeit erfahrung auf eine
besondere weise verbunden
und jetzt müssen wir uns noch die frage
stellen wie die dimensionen der zeit
also vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft wie
die mit dem subjekt derzeit erfahrung
zusammenhängen und ich sagte schon der
letzten sitzung augustinus hat eine sehr
elaborierte sehr originelle theorie wir
mit bezug auf das subjekt derzeit
erfahrung dieses ontologische problem
also wie die zeit bzw die vergangenheit
und die zukunft speziell überhaupt
existieren kann wo sie doch letztendlich
entweder noch nicht sind wie die zukunft
oder nicht mehr sind wie die
vergangenheit also wie kann er das jetzt
zeigen dass sie dennoch eine realität
haben wo sie doch eigentlich gar nicht
eigentlichen sinne existieren oder
wirklich sind aktuell sind die zukunft
die hat die potenz als potenziell
existiert aber eben noch nicht aktuell
und ich wirklich und die vergangenheit
die existierte mal aber nicht mehr
und mit der gegenwart ist es ja genauso
erinnern sie sich noch haben sie meine
zusammenfassung bekommen per e-mail war
die hilfreich für sie oder hat sie
jemand nicht bekommen dann einfach nicht
bitte anschalten wenn er oder sie nicht
bekommen hat und in der in der gegenwart
ist es so dass die gegenwart wie
augustinus sagt sich eigentlich gar
nicht erstrecken kann
sie kann gar keine dimensionen haben
weil werden sie sich erstrecken würde in
der zeit
wenn das die gegenwart wäre
in der zeitleiste schreiben hierhin t
ja was wäre dann das dann könnte man
dann mit dieser ausgedehnten zeit die
die gegenwart angeblich seien zu tun
ja genau
man könnte sagen ja gut dann teilen wir
sie in zwei teile
dann ist das hier dieser teil hier ist
die zukunft und das hier ist die
vergangenheit und die können wir dann
wieder wegnehmen die zukunft die
existiert ja noch nicht von die
vergangenheit existiert nicht mehr
und dann könnte man sagt ja gut dieses
kleine dann haben wir wieder so ein ganz
kleines zeit teilchen wenn wir wieder
also augustinus spricht ja wirklich von
teil stellen wenn sie mal einen
lateinischen text kopf gucken ich habe
ihnen das auch in der zusammenfassung
habe ich auch immer die lateinischen
wichtigsten wendung angegeben wenn sie
das sich nochmal anschauen und dann
könnte man theoretisch dieses kleine
zeit teilchen wieder unterm mikroskop
betrachten und wird dann feststellen
hoppla es ist vielleicht wieder
ausgedehnt können wir wieder dasselbe
machen dass wir die möglichkeit oder man
muss einfach zu geben
tja so oft ich dasselbe wiederholen
ich komme doch immer dazu dass die
gegenwart nicht ausgedient sein kann
also begrifflich kann sie nicht
ausgedient sein weil sonst würde sie
wieder zerfallen diese zwei teilen
also ist ein riesenproblem wie wir mit
der gegenwart umzugehen haben und jetzt
lesen wir mal weiter im text
ich lese einfach mal vor
also fragt wer ist es denn der mir
weismachen will es geben nicht drei
zeiten nicht vergangenheit gegenwart und
zukunft die wir als kinder gelernt und
wie wir die kinder gelehrt haben sondern
nur die gegenwart die da die beiden
anderen zeiten ja nicht sind oder sind
sie doch aber so dass das gegenwärtige
wenn ich es aus dem zug wenn es aus dem
zukünftigen entsteht aus irgendeinem
dunkel hervortritt und birgit an dunkel
regen ein dunkel zurückweicht das dunkel
der vergangenheit wenn aus dem
gegenwärtigen vergangenes wird wo haben
wir denn weissagen und das zukünftige
gesehen wenn es noch nicht ist denn was
nicht ist kann auch nicht gesehen werden
der vergangenes erzählt könnte
keinesfalls wahres erzählen wer es nicht
im geist wahrnehmen hätte das vergangene
kainz sein könnte es überhaupt nicht
wahrgenommen werden also kommt auch den
zukünftigen und den vergangen sein
zu
wie kann man das vergangene wahrnehmen
haben sie eine idee ja genau also wir
haben zu jedem und das ist jetzt die
pointe von augustinus wir haben zu jeder
dimension oder zu jedem stadium so habe
ich sie an einer zusammenfassung genannt
zu jedem stadium derzeit haben wir ein
eigenes app ist ökologisches erkenntnis
theoretisches vermögen oder genau
genommen ein erkenntnistheoretischen
zugang eine erkenntnis theoretisch
zugangsweisen die zugangsweisen szenisch
auf die vergangenheit ist geben die
erinnerung und jetzt hatte mir ein
kommilitone dankenswerterweise jetzt
ende der letzten sitzung noch darauf
hingewiesen dass wir uns die
vergangenheit die gegenwart und die
zukunft auch noch mal anders vorstellen
können und theologisch nämlich als ein
raum zeit wurm ich mal immerhin
das so das ist jetzt ein raum zeit wo
also wir haben hier die zeit und die
haben wir beziehungsweise hier haben wir
genau wie kann man sich einen raum zeit
wohl vorstellen
das ist ein raum zeit wohnt
der raumzeit warum ist der versuch die
vergangenheit die vergangenheit
jedenfalls nur und dann wenn dass der
gegenstand geben am ende gefunden hat
sei jetzt man habe jedenfalls die
vergangenheit selbst in die ontologie in
das ein des dings mit aufzunehmen
letztendlich müssen sich das so
vorstellen sie bewegen sich in raum und
zeit
solange sie existieren sie bewegen sich
von einem ort zum anderen und die
ontologie des raumzeit wurms also sie
wären jeder von ihnen wäre ein solcher
bauzeit wurden die anträge des raumzeit
worden sagt dass sie jetzt endlich auch
in der vergangenheit existiert und es
würden sich sofort auch zugeben dass wir
auch in der vergangenheit existiert
hatten aber auf so eine weise dass sie
wenn sie ihre gesamte existenz
betrachten dass sie einen solchen wurm
ergeben also zu einer bestimmten zeit in
der vergangenheit haben sie sich hier
befunden das ist jetzt die räumliche
situation und zu einer anderen zeit
haben sie sich hier kunden das heißt sie
ziehen sich mit ihrer existenz durch
raum und zeit hindurch und hinterlassen
so eine spur raumzeit spur und diese
raumzeit spur kann man selbst auch in
form eines wurms also einer solchen
dreidimensionalen gebildet das sich
durch die zeit hindurch zieht auch
verstehen
und der vorteil eines solchen raumzeit
wunsch einer solchen schlange die sich
eben theologisch auch durch die zeit
zieht ist die dass die vergangenheit
stets zu ihnen gehört als ein teil wenn
sie gewöhnlich sich betrachten ihre
existenz dann sind sie substanzen
sie sind abgegrenzte individuen zu
bestimmten zeitpunkten und der vorteile
dieses raumzeit uns ist
dass ihre vergangenen bewegungen ihre
vergangen existenzen nicht einfach
gewichtet wird der vergangenheit sind
dass sie mit berücksichtigt werden im
inter- und logie und dann sehen sie so
aus und sie sich als eine zeitliche
existenz verstehen deren vergangenheit
immer mit im spiel ist
es gibt verschiedene ontologien wie sich
vorstellen können ja die zukunft jetzt
noch nicht unbedingt also dir die
vergangenheit ich hatte gesagt nur die
vergangenheit fallen also jetzt ist die
gegenwart hier
und das geht ist noch offen aber die
vergangenheit können sie jederzeit
bestimmen und sie waren zu diesem
zeitpunkt sage ich mal
die zwei waren sie an diesem ort hier in
diesem raum punkt und dann können sie
das so verstehen die zukunft ist jetzt
noch offen nehmen wir mal ein gewisses
haustier ein haustier lebt irgendwann
nicht mehr
das heißt das haustier ist dort
gestorben
am 21 und dann ist das die existent ist
das sagen die die raum zeitliche
existenz dass das haustier ist aber
tatsächlich sie haben recht die zukunft
können wir uns mit seinem raum zeit
wurden schlecht abbilden dies noch offen
es sei denn wir gehen von einem
determinismus aus das alles eben schon
vorher bestimmt ist das wäre auch
möglich dann können wir den raum zeit
warum einfach projiziere zukunft
ausrechnen wo wir uns zu welcher zeit
finden müssen also es wäre dann so
geht's weiter wir müssen uns dann hier
befinden und dann ergibt sich irgendwie
sowas könnte man das auch noch
ausrechnen aber das betrifft ein anderes
thema determination und unsere sache
aber ich wollte nur weil ein kommilitone
des dankenswerterweise ins spiel
gebracht hat ihnen sagen man kann sich
die eigene existenz auch so vorstellen
durch einen raum zeit wurden
vergegenwärtigen und dann macht die
vergangenheit überhaupt kein problem
weil sie ist teil unserer selbst wir
haben raum zeitliche teile so das sagen
geht es nicht davon aus dass wir schon
mal
wer gegeben hat auch aktive erfassen
weil diese wahrscheinlich es ist doch
erinnerungen auch im nachhinein form
worten veränderbar
wie verändert sich auch die erste zeit
ja ein guter punkt also wie ist es mit
der stilisierung mit der interpretation
von von vergangenheit
augustinus hatte ja sehr objektiv ist
isches verständnis von vergangenheit
gesagt es gibt ein ein faktum der
vergangenheit darüber lässt sich nicht
diskutieren das ist nicht
interpretationssache also es war der
fall dass ich mich am soundsovielten
januar 2010 an diesem ort verhalten
gefunden hatte und dann kommt dieser
raum zeit wurden
das ist einfach objektiv davon geht er
aus sie sprechen natürlich in anderen
wichtigen punkt an das natürlich
vergangenheit und auch zukunft aber
speziell vergangenheit immer der deutung
ausgesetzt ist
das ist das problem der
geschichtswissenschaft wie interpretiert
man also eine hermeneutik wie
interpretiert man die vergangenheit man
kann der gsh die dasselbe historische
ereignis auf ganz unterschiedliche weise
interpretieren was seine bedeutung
anbelangt vor allem was seine kausale
bedeutung anbelangt also die frage war
jetzt dieses ereignis die ursache von
jenem oder waren beide die wirkung von
einem anderen traten sie nur zufällig
auf das wäre ein punkt den jetzt
augustinus so nicht im auge hat er
interessiert sich sehr für diese fakten
also was passiert da da da also war ich
da zum beispiel an diesem zeitpunkt und
das ist denke ich objektiv kann
erinnerung eines faktors müsste man dazu
sagen
die erinnerung dass ich da war ich war
da und das ist klar ich habe mich vor
zehn jahren in new york gefunden new
york auf dem times square
da war ich und das ist ein faktor er
denkt ihr sohn also recht objektives
tisch
das ist ein weiterer punkt der uns noch
ein bisschen schwieriger ja aber was die
zukunft anbelangt ist es dir so dass
einfach davon ausgeht es gab ein faktum
und ich muss nicht dessen einfach noch
erinnern können dieses faktum
und wenn ich es kann dann habe ich eben
diesen modus erinnerung aber sie sagen
wichtig er bindet das an das subjekt er
bindet das anders erkennen das objekt
interessant auch verstehen mit
sicherheit gibt es das dass wir es jetzt
nur bezogen auf endlich individuums
sowie es sind also jeder von uns wird
mal nach dieser anthologie so aussehen
zieht auch schon so aus die frage ist
wie lange dieser wurm ist das ist die
einzige war und wie welche kurven er hat
also wo er sich im raum befindet
diese raumzeit wurm kommt auch
letztendlich ist es so eine idee die
angriffs an einsteins
relativitätstheorie wirklich wurde sie
kennen vielleicht den minkowski raum
schon mal gehört mit kowski raum das ist
einfach der raum den wir in der zeit
ausfüllen können wo wir uns prinzipiell
befinden können gesetz dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit begrenzt ist auf
300 tausend kilometer pro sekunde
wir können einfach in einem kegel das
ist wie ein kegel und nicht aus dem
kegel heraus weil der kegel definiert
ist durch die lichtgeschwindigkeit und
schneller als sie die geschwindigkeit
können wir nach dieser auffassung nicht
sein
und ganz ähnlich läuft es auch so da
bezieht man die zeit mit in die
ontologie ein und dann bekommt man so
ein dreidimensionales gebilde was ich
eben in der zeit erstreckt und nicht nur
im raum normalerweise sagt man ja dann
hat ein gebilde das einmal ein zylinder
und der zylinder dehnt sich aus dem raum
ist also 10 cm hoch und 5 cm breit und
13 5 cm lang
so könnte man zu beschreiben und bei
dieser bei diesem raum zeit wurden kommt
eben als eine weitere dimension oder
beschreibung achse noch die zeit hinzu
er hat mich nur diese räumliche
ausdehnung sondern auch noch diese
zeitlich also er existierte in dieser
räumlichen verfasstheit fünf jahre dann
muss ich ihn eben praktisch wie sowieso
ein wurm zahlen der eben derzeit gedient
ist und das heißt nicht dass da nicht
auch noch eine vergangenheit
möglich ist nur irgendwann wurde eben
der zylinder hergestellt er hat einen
ganz klar anfangspunkt und er hat je
nachdem wie man es fast auch ein
endpunkt zu endpunkt schwierig wann hört
der zylinder auf zu existieren wenn wir
uns jetzt mal als ein gegenstand
vorstellen dann wenn die spitze abbricht
wenn er seine form nicht mehr besetzt
wenn wir ihn ein schmelzen wenn er jetzt
kosten metall ist aus plastik bei uns
genau dasselbe gut bei uns würde man
sagen wird wenn wir eben nicht mehr
leben oder als wie geboren wurden die
frage aber wann ist unser beginn ist es
mit der zeugung ist es mit der
empfängnis ganz schwierige frage diese
endpunkte der zeitlichen existenz aber
ich spiele jetzt für augustinus nicht so
eine große rolle ihm geht es erst mal
nur einfach darum dass wenn etwas wahr
wenn etwas gewesen ist dass ich dann die
frage stellt wie es existiert wenn es
gewesen ist welcher modus das was mal
war existieren und seine lösung ist eben
die dass er sagt es existiert aber nur
in einem modus der subjektivität aber
nicht in den modus der subjektivität zu
verstanden dass es jetzt relativ wäre
jeder kann das anders sehen und das ist
eben vom subjekt abhängt wie es ein app
ästhetischen zugang her steht zu dem was
gewesen ist und der modus in dem
vergangen ist existiert ist und hier
klingt eben schon an die erinnerung und
jetzt wollen wir mal weiter gehen zum
nächsten zitat
also hat er jetzt hier die erinnerungen
schon genannt und jetzt geh auf's
nächste zitat über falls ins zukünftiges
um vergangenes gibt will ich wissen wo
sie sind das ist ihre frage auch gewesen
wo sind sie obwohl ich das noch nicht
sagen kann weil sich doch
weil sich doch dass sie dort wo immer
sie sein mögen nicht zukunft wo du
vergangen sondern gegenwärtig sind
denn wenn sie auch dort zukünftig sind
sind sie dort noch nicht wenn sie auch
dort vergangen sind sind sie dort nicht
mehr wo immer sie also sind was sie auch
sind sind nur wenn sie gegenwärtig sind
wenn man war das erzählt holt man
vergangenes aus dem gedächtnis hervor
das sind aber nicht die sachen selbst
die vorüber gegangen sind sondern worte
die man aus bildern der sachen
aufgenommen hat diese sachen haben beim
vorübergehen im kreis durch die sinne
spuren in das gedächtnis eingeprägt
und jetzt lesen wir das nächste das hat
noch mit hinzu meine kindheit die nicht
mehr ist ist gewiss in der vergangenen
zeit die nicht mehr ist rufe ich sie mit
auch ins gedächtnis und erzähle von ihr
so schaue ich ihr bild in der gegenwart
weil sie mir noch im gedächtnis ist ich
gestehe mein gott nicht zu wissen dass
er hat diese theologische kontext ob
auch die vorhersage von zukünftigen eine
ähnliche ursache hat dann könnten bilder
von etwas was noch nicht ist im voraus
wahrgenommen werden als ob diese schon
existierten wohl weiß ich dass wir
unsere zukünftigen handlungen meist im
voraus bedenken
und dass das darüber dass das vordenkern
gegenwärtig ist ich weiß aber auch dass
eine handlung die wir vor bedenken noch
nicht da ist noch nicht ist da sie
zukünftig ist erst wenn wir
herangetreten sind und zu tun begonnen
haben was wir bedacht hatten wird die
handlung sein weil sie dann nicht zu
künftig sein wird sondern gegenwerte ist
also auch hier wieder die problematik
wie wir zukünftiges und vergangenes und
theologisch zu verstehen haben hatte
sich jemand noch gemeldet diesen zitaten
sonst mache ich noch das nächste wahl
jetzt kommt gleich die pointe wie es als
auch mit dem geheimnisvollen voraussehen
von zukünftigen stehen mag gesehen
werden kann nur etwas was ist was aber
schon ist ist nicht zukünftig sondern
gegenwärtig wenn man also sagt das
zukünftige zukünftiges gesehen wird wird
es nicht selbst gesehen weil es noch
nicht ist ermöglicht werden aber aber
von ihm gründe oder zeichen gesehen
diese sind schon da deshalb sind sie für
die diese schon sehen nicht zukünftig
sollen gegenwärtig aus ihnen können sie
zukünftiges voraussagen dass im geist
erfasst wurde
dass voraussagen das kleine
die vorstellung wiederum sind schon da
wer also zukünftiges voraus sagt er
blickt diese weiß nicht gegenwärtig das
ist jetzt eine spannende fragen wieso
kann jetzt derjenige der zukünftiges
voraussagt dass tatsächlich schon
voraussagen wenn es eigentlich doch noch
nicht ist was ist sein argument jetzt
wenn ich jetzt eine prognose mache und
mich auch darin nicht irre was ist jetzt
das argument genau das ist ein guter
punkt zb mögliche soziale faktoren
es gibt ja eine ursache die ist ihm
jetzt schon angelegt und diese ursache
die schließt logisch schon fast oder
analytisch in sich eine wirkung
das heißt ich kann aus der ursache die
jetzt existiert logisch schon fast in
dem ich weiter denke auf die zukunft
schließen die aber sich aus der
folgerung einer gegenwärtigen situation
oder eines gegenwärtigen ereignisse gibt
als auch bei vorhersagen sagen wir aus
der gegenwart in die vergangenheit
vorher
viele werden auch die vergangenheit noch
nie dabei reiht bei diesem grausamen
zukunft weil wir diese sogenannte
kausalität aus erfahrung hat mit
erfahrung tatsachen aus der
vergangenheit darum ein
wirtschaftspolitisches oder persönliche
vorhersagen das ist die erfahrung da
dass die dgn dem und dem qualitäts
zusammenhang ablaufen und alle belege
dafür finde ich in der vergangenheit das
ist ein gutes argument dass man sagt
also wie kann ich denn auf die zukunft
schließen rein aus dagegen wird wenn ich
doch schließen kann nur deshalb weil ich
immer wieder aus der vergangenheit
gelernt habe weil ich jetzt endlich
etwas generalisieren also kausalität so
verstanden
es hat sich tausendmal immer so
verhalten wenn adam b 1000 mal war das
der fall
in der vergangenheit daraus schließlich
es wird sich auch in zukunft zu
verhalten das wäre dann so eine art
induktions schluss das wäre möglichkeit
das ist natürlich ein induktives
verständnis von kausalität was die
vergangenheit voraussetzt es gibt aber
auch verständnis von kausalität die
nicht induktiv simpson die einfach
logisch sind dass man sagt wenn ich
etwas als eine ursache jetzt erkenne
dann weiß ich apriori also unabhängig
von erfahrung dass die wirkung so sein
wird
alles hängt irgendwie immer davon ab wie
man sich kausalität können wir endlich
politischen raum ist ein gutes argument
dass man sagt also in niebels welchen
zusammenhängen können wir nur so kausal
dem dass wir sagen es war in der
vergangenheit schon so gewesen und
daraus schließen wir dass es so sein
wird und wie könnte man jetzt darauf
antworten auf so 1000 verständnis was
lebens wirklich bestimmt zutreffend ist
wie könnte man dieses verkaufs helfer
stellten dennoch unter logisch in die
gegenwart beziehen
damit man nicht zahlen müsste ja das ist
doch alles aus dem nichts sein der
geschützt das ist ja genau noch so dass
werden machen
bei der qualität die ursachen der kunde
muss ertragen dass man alte die
vergangenheit sich irgendwie
vergegenwärtigen müsste also dass man
sie vielleicht in ihre wirkung ganz klar
wird also dass man von der wirkung
besser nicht von der ursache ausgeht
also wenn es um die zukunft geht geht
man von der ursache aus und schließt
darauf auf die zukunft und jetzt könnte
man das vielleicht anders machen dass
man sagt wir gehen was die vergangenheit
anbelangen wir gehen von der wirkung aus
nicht von der ursache wirkung und
schließen von der wirkung auf die
ursache
also können uns dadurch der
vergangenheit annähern wird es ihr punkt
so ein bisschen gewesen oder wollte er
dass der punkt ist ja eben den wir
besprechen das wenn man die zukunft
vorhersagt sagt rose
dass diese ursachen der brände aus der
erfahrung kommen müssen dann aber was
augustinus lag das ist ja immer
das wenn man von dem wetter gar nicht an
die vergangenheit denkt dass man die
ja also wir kommen noch drauf augustinus
wird dann wie sie schon richtig sein für
jede dimension für jedes stadium derzeit
ein eigentliches eigentliches
subjektives vermögen oder eine subjektiv
systemische erkenntnistheoretische
aktion einen modus anführen und was die
gegenwart und die vergangenheit
anbelangt ist es eben das
vergegenwärtigen das ist ein modus das
dann hinüber zu holen von der
vergangenheit durch die erinnerung in
die gegenwart
jetzt hatten sie sich auch noch der
kausale verknüpfung zu eng ist
vielleicht könnte man auch von
korrelationen versprechen ist nicht
etwas ist bedingt durch was vorher
passiert ist sondern das hängt zusammen
in viele sternchen da sind gibt es für
die kinder ich weiß nicht ob es einen
prozess ist gleich auftreten
also das ist ja so wie aktuell ja auch
suchmaschinen funktionieren
die zahlen zusammen dann gesucht so ein
statistisches problem ist eben immer ein
guter punkt das eben bei solchen
korrelationen wie die absolute
gewissheit gegeben dass es könnte sich
ihren bisher immer so verhalten haben in
korrelation und in der zukunft dann
irgendwann nicht mehr als solches
herausstellen das ist ein punkt den in
der geschichte der philosophie david
hume habe mal hin diese englische
philosoph bzw
es war eigentlich ein schotte david jung
als ein ein schottischer in paris der
hat irgendwie these vertreten dass wenn
mich das brot was ich täglich es in der
vergangenheit immer genähert hat könnte
es dennoch sein dass es mich irgendwann
nicht mehr nähert in der zukunft das
ergibt sich aus dem begriff des brotes
logisch oder
ab rio risch wie kant dann sagen würde
also einfach aus dem rhein begriff
heraus dass es so sein muss denn ich
glaube augustinus hatten ihr objektives
tisches verständnis von kausalität
obwohl er hier von kausalität gar nicht
spricht
aber sie sagen zu recht dass man
natürlich auch so einer statistischen
oder core relativen begriff verwenden
könnte man müsste aber dann immer noch
eine zusätzliche prämisse einführen
wonach die vergangenheit der gegenwart
und der zukunft gleicht das also die
verhältnisse der korrelation stabil
bleiben über die zeit entdeckung das
muss man eben nicht akzeptieren das ist
eine zusatzeinnahme die zum beispiel
david hume bestritten hatten und dass
man das also annehmen müsste die
gleichförmigkeit der entwicklung
innerhalb der zeit ist würde man sich
damit noch erkaufen
das lese ich aber mal weiter
ein beliebiges beispiel soll die anzahl
möglicher fälle klarstellen ich sehe das
morgenrot und sage den sonnenaufgang
voraus was ich sehe ist gegenwärtig das
morgenrot was ich voraussage zukünftig
nicht die sonne der schon sein zukunft
kommt ist zukünftig sondern ihr aufgang
dem noch kein seien zu kunden kommt doch
könnte ich auch den anfangs selbst nicht
vorhersagen wenn ich ihn mir nicht im
geiste ausmalt wie jetzt wenn ich das
sage aber weder jenes morgenroth dass
ich am himmel sehen ist der
sonnenaufgang
es ist erst ihr vorausgehend mag noch
jene vorstellung in meinen geist beide
werden zwar als gegenwärtig erfasst aber
nur so dass jener als zukünftig
vorhergesagt wird zukünftiges ist
demnach noch nicht und wenn es noch
nicht ist ist es nicht und wenn es nicht
ist kann es kein falsch gesehen werden
doch lässt es sich aus gegenwärtigen
vorhersagen
das schon da ist und gesehen wird hier
kommt natürlich ihr punkt wieder ein
spieler immer wenn das morgen gut ist
kommt dann die sonne also in der
vergangenheit war das immer so
also erscheint schon davon auszugehen
dass das immer so sein wird
eine zusätzliche prämie ist es könnte ja
irgendwann mal sein überlegen sie mal
ich weiß nicht wie viel milliarden
jahren ab irgendwann gibt die sonne
nicht mehr da gibt es dann vielleicht
morgenroth aber keine sonne mehr ist los
ist logisch möglich
also ich glaube aber auch dass
augustinus hier nicht so extrem strengen
hier vorgeht sein es geht ihm um
illustrationen und beispiele so und
jetzt kommt das entscheidende zitat
gleich jetzt geht es demnächst also
jetzt in diesem zitat ist das wichtigste
da geht es jetzt sozusagen um die lösung
und diese subjektivität theoretische
lösung dieses dilemmas oder paradoxes
derzeit man kann nur durch aussagen
augustinus hat hier ein dilemma vor sich
wie kann denn zukünftiges um vergangenes
sein wo es doch noch nicht bzw nicht
mehr ist das ist ein dilemma und wo wir
doch eigentlich im lebensweltlichen
kontexten sehr selbstverständlich und
sehr sinnvoll von solchen dingen wie
zukünftigen und vergangenen sprechen als
wäre es da ja wir reden präsent ist ish
präsentes von vergangenen und
zukünftigen wir behandeln es als ob es
gegenwärtig wären und das ist ein
durchaus ein dilemma und augustinus hat
dazu eine lösung und die kommt jetzt in
diesem zitat auf seite 35
und wie alles bei augustinus das hatte
ich in der letzten sitzung schon gesagt
hängt dass die lösung mit dem thema
subjektivität zusammen genau genommen
mit dem thema reflexivität also
augustinus ist der erste denker könnte
man sagen der subjektivität er ist auch
der erste denker des willens im heutigen
sinne und vielleicht auch der
willensfreiheit wie wir sie heutzutage
verstehen und der schlüsselbegriff der
ihm es erlaubt diese ganzen dilemmata
erlöst viele probleme auf diese weise
zum beispiel auch das problem der frage
ob ich überhaupt existieren die beide
card als erlösung die lösung zu diesem
dilemma da ist immer die subjektivität
und das ist ein begriff oder ein modus
der existenz denen die antiken also
platon aristoteles so noch nicht kannten
es gibt sicherlich vor form auch des
willens auch der subjektivität aber es
ist eher eine und logische weise wie die
antiken platon aristoteles von zeit
denken wir werden in der zweiten hälfte
oder auch jetzt gleich auf aristoteles
noch zu sprechen kommen es ist eine
objektive weise wie wir wie die antiken
also aristoteles platon
die welt verstehen und bei augustinus
kommt eine ganz starke form von
subjektivität ins spiel
die jetzt aber nicht gleichzusetzen ist
mit relativ oder beliebigkeit es ist
eher ein modus eine präsenz reise in der
sich die welt uns zeigt und durch die
wir die welt und ihre probleme ihre
dilemmata die sich uns bieten besser
verstehen können und jetzt kommt eben
das entscheidendste tat gelesen vor
das jedoch ist jetzt deutlich klar weder
zukünftiges noch vergangenes ist diese
besonderheit derzeit verfehlt man wenn
man sagt es gibt drei zeiten die
vergangene die gegenwärtige und die
zukünftigen zutreffen könnte man
vielleicht sagen es gibt drei zeiten
nämlich gegenwart von vergangenen
gegenwart von gegenwärtigen und
gegenwart von zukünftigen denn diese
drei zeiten sind gewissermaßen in der
seele subjektivität da anderswo aber sie
ich sie nicht
es gibt gegenwart von vergangen nämlich
erinnerung gegenwart von gegenwärtigen
nämlich anschauen gegenwart von
zukünftigen nämlich erwartung könnte
auch noch hin zu setzen vielleicht
hoffnung das war's aber erwartung ist
nur objektive wenn man uns so zu
sprechen erlaubt sehe ich drei zeit und
gebe zu dass es drei sind
man mag weiter sagen dass vergangenheit
gegenwart und zukunft die drei zeiten
sein wie uns die gewohnheit das sagen
verleitet mag man so reden sie ich sorge
mich nicht darum wie das jetzt nämlich
nicht und über keine kritik wenn man bei
alledem nur versteht was man sagt und
nicht behauptet dass was zukünftig ist
sei schon oder das was vergangen ist sei
noch noch nicht sei sei nicht muss es
heißen denn nur wenig benennen wir zu
treffen das meiste um zu treffen und
doch versteht man was wir sagen
also nochmal jetzt sondern auf den
begriff gebracht was ist jetzt die
lösung dieses dilemmas dieses problems
das vergangenes und zukünftiges
eigentlich doch gar nicht sein kann was
was sagt das augustinus hier über den
begriff der seele der subjektivität wie
kann er dieses problem lösen
so müssen das glück zeit wo es
existieren und wir machen aus all diesen
verein zahlt einfach aus gegenwärtiges
da dies ein guter punkt vergegenwärtigt
die zukunft und die vergangenheit zieht
sie ins jetzt hinein oder er setzt sich
in bezug auf sie über die gegenwart oder
bezieht sie auf die gegenwart jeweils
und was ist die gegenwart vergehen
das ist glaube jetzt ist ganz
entscheidende diese six hier das pixi
ist nicht nur irgendwie einen zeitpunkt
oder die abstrakte gegenwart sondern des
iks ist ein subjekt das dix ist ein
wesen was sich verhalten kann zurzeit
das ist das ganz entscheidend also
aristoteles auf dem jetzt gleich noch zu
sprechen kommen der letzten halben
stunde der denkt zu wissen nicht wie sie
zugibt
der denkt die zeit ziemlich objektives
tisch
die zeit gemessen an der zahl die zahl
dass es so dieses kriterium und die zahl
hat bei augustinus der natürlich
zeitlich historisch nach aristoteles kam
wir haben jetzt hier somit kleine
verordnung vorgenommen hätten auch mit
aristoteles beginnen können aber ich
denke der kontrast wird deutlicher
die zahl spiel bei augustinus keine
rolle er hat also nicht so ein fan
gegenwert für gegenständliche das
verständnis von zeit sondern tatsächlich
ein recht subjektives ohne wie gesagt
die zeit dadurch relativ werden zu
lassen
also hier diese sticks ist das objekt
und das subjekt das setzt die zukunft
mit der gegenwart in beziehung natürlich
auch mit der vergangenheit das subjekt
leistet die bezüglich kite dieser drei
stadien dieser drei relation oder
dimensionen derzeit das ist so die
entscheidende pointe
und wie kann er jetzt dieses problem
lösen sie es haben schon angedeutet wie
kann er es lösen also sagt er zieht es
auf das objekt
überzeugt sie das was ist jetzt sagen
der der schlüssel wie redet er jetzt von
von der zukunft und von der
vergangenheit von diesem subjekt
ausgehen ich werde ich mich als ich das
alles wäre weil er bei der wahrnehmung
von zukunft oder das wahrnehmung von
vergangenheit plötzlich dass die
objektive zukunft oder die objektive ist
es die klassik guter punkt also ich
glaube nicht dass augustinus sagen
möchte dass das was zukünftig ist von
meiner subjektivität abhängen
das könnte man jetzt zu lesen das also
was zukünftig ist davon bestimmt wird
wie ich mich dazu verhalte das glaube
ich nichts an er geht davon aus es gibt
etwas objektiv fest stehend zukünftiges
was irgendwann mal gegen fertig wird es
ist völlig unabhängig was der gehalt die
in zukunft ist es völlig egal was
geschehen wird sondern es geht darum wie
das zurzeit nämlich einstellung sich das
subjekt zu dem was mal sein wird
verhelfen und damit ist nicht gesagt
dass die einstellung des subjekts
bestimmt war es zukünftig sein wird das
wäre tatsächlich dann zu einer art von
kapitalismus oder konstruktivismus im
ganz radikalen sinne sondern ist einfach
letztendlich ein modus könnte man sagen
ein modus in dem sich das subjekt
vergegenwärtigen auf dem zukunft richtet
und der modus ist die erwartung also
nicht ist es nicht so dass alles was
erwartet wird auch so eintreten muss
also es kann zum beispiel auch sein dass
sich das die erwartung und täuscht dass
wir uns in unserer erwartung täuschen
nichtsdestotrotz haben wir das erwartet
wir werden dann in der erwartung
sagen in der erwartung korrigiert aber
es ist dennoch der modus der erwartungen
mit denen wir uns dem gegend mit dem wir
uns dem zukünftigen in verbindung setzen
auch wenn wir dann uns der modus bleibt
dass es geht als er sein um die
abstrakte form um die form der
bezugnahme auf zukünftiges unabhängig
davon was jetzt der gehalt des
zukünftigen sein mag zum beispiel auch
getäuscht werden oder enttäuscht werden
wären genauso vergegenwärtigung der
zukunft ja da habe ich mich eben gehört
dann aber dass ich mich überhaupt irren
kann oder dass ich mich irre ist eine
form der erwartung jetzt hatten sie sich
gemeldet
unglaublich
keine angst vor so könne das doch
mit dem
versuche genau als ich kann ganz
verschiedene die zukunft erwarten die
zwei objekte können in derselben
situation der selben zeit völlig
entgegengesetzte von der zukunft
erwarten
es gibt pessimisten es gibt optimist die
eine person erwartet von der zukunft nur
das beste also wohlstand und frieden auf
erden
die andere person erwartet armut und
krieg gegenüber derselben zukunft wie
dieses zukunft dann sein wird ist offen
wer ist gut er würde natürlich sagen es
gibt schon wie ein vorheriges tat es
gibt schon anzeichen
es gibt also anzeichen in der gegenwart
und von denen aus können wir dann
schließen aber es geht jetzt erst mal
nur ganz allgemein darum wie wir uns
öffnen wir uns beziehen auf die zukunft
und das ist zukünftig existiert nur oder
wird nur insofern gegenwärtig für uns
als wir uns in einem bestimmten modus
auf es was auch immer es sein mag
beziehen
als wir müssen eigentlich wenn wir das
jetzt wieder grafisch veranschaulichen
müssen müssen wir eigentlich zwei pfeile
machen
also wir haben hier das ixs wieder in
der mitte und hier ist die zukunft
hier ist die vergangenheit und jetzt ist
es so dass augustinus ja dieses dieses
beruhende zeitverständnis hat also bzw
er hat dieses zeitverständnis was diese
six anbelangt dass diese sixx das
ruhende ist nicht dass ich in der zeit
bewegen also das ruht jetzt sozusagen
die zeit zieht hindurch und nicht witzig
und jetzt kommt es entscheidend das
subjekt das subjekt es kann erwarten
und es kann erinnern wo indem es diese
diesem modus existiert vergegenwärtigt
es auf eine formale art als nicht auf
eine inhaltliche darauf eine formale art
die beiden eigentlich noch nicht und
nicht mehr sein denn staaten derzeit
also es bezieht sie letztendlich auf
sich in sich hinein durch verhältnisse
die es angeht und das ist die
möglichkeit nach augustinus eben auf
eine recht objektive weise von
vergangenheit und zukunft zu sprechen
die natürlich am ende durch das subjekt
vermittelt sind als wir bekommen
objektiv die möglichkeit objektiv über
rahmen über vergangenheit und gegenwart
zu sprechen in seinem sinne dass wir sie
als präsent ansehen können nur dadurch
dass wir sie auf ein subjekt beziehen
was über verschiedene vermögen verfügt
wie die erinnerung und die antizipation
leistung und natürlich auch noch das
vergegenwärtigen
das ist natürlich ein punkt also der der
trick schon jetzt es sein die
objektivität der sinnvollen rede über
zukünftiges und vergangenes als auch
prima partie einig paradox sein könnte
weil es ja noch nicht ist so
herzustellen dass wir es auf das objekt
beziehen was sich in verhältnissen
befindet das ist offensichtlich die
lösung jetzt hatten sich mit
ja genau als eigentlich müssten sogar
beide teile immer in beide richtungen
seien
es ist ein sich beziehen eine rück
bisschen ein wechselverhältnis
letztendlich aber ebenso dass es die man
noch im modus der subjektivität ist und
jetzt haben wir noch einen weiteren
mutter die hatte ich vergessen gleich
dann haben wir noch ein modus nämlich
die anschauen hier die anschauung wäre
letztendlich dann ein pfeil auf sich
zurück könnte man sagen also dieser
geschlossen
das wäre dann vielleicht sowas wie die
an charles hatte sich hier noch 1
kommentar diese worte nicht existent das
heißt wir können uns eine welt
vorstellen die so frei ist
die luft zu werfen und vermögen letzter
zeit und die werden also nicht so wie
ich als die objekte offensichtlich nicht
infrage rede die diese zeit wächst
vergangenheit gute verein ist voll die
hand genau das ist sehr gute frage
ich kann es wieder vorweg greifen wir
hatten ja schon gesehen es gibt so 22
verständnis es gibt eine zeit
verständnis dass ihr so ein
arithmetisches zeitverständnis das
einfach so eine puppe abfolge von
ereignissen
da interessiert dann nicht was es
zukünftig und was ist vergangen weil wir
weil diese six nicht interessiert diese
sixx wird beliebig wir können dieses
x-beliebige ansätzen einem zeitstrahl
ich mach das mal kurz aus
vielleicht die mal kurz zurück das egal
hier sieht man den zeitstrahl wir können
uns das so vorstellen geht besonders
endlich zurückgeht bis ins unendliche
voraus und uns interessiert hier immer
nur der jeweilige zeitpunkt uns
interessiert nicht wie sich dieser
zeitpunkt zu zukünftigen vergangenen
verhält als es gibt ein sehr abstraktes
zeitverständnis das zeit verständnis der
physik wo eben nur vorher früher oder
später relation gelten als ganz objektiv
man kann sagen dass die 2
das sei die 130 oder kann man eben sagen
so die null ist größer als die 1 oder
ist eben praktisch jünger t1 ist älter
oder war vorher c2 war vor 1 und 2 0
solche solche bezüge was war früher was
war später das ist ein sehr abstraktes
zeitverständnis dass das wäre dann sagen
angemessen für diesen fall der ursuppe
wo nur ein zähler bakterien vielleicht
auch nur ja dinosaurier existieren ja da
bin ich mir nicht sicher wie es da ist
also die frage ist letztendlich die
frage nach geschichte also wo tritt
wirklich geschichte auf das ist jetzt
das abstrakte physikalische verständnis
und jetzt gibt es aber noch ein anderes
dass man sich fragt zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt
fast schon was hat es mit der
vergangenheit mit der gegenwart aufsicht
also die vergangenheit in die gegenwart
die spiele nach diesem ersten
verständnis keine rolle
die gegenwart die gegenwart spielt nur
dann eine rolle wenn wir ins objekt
ansetzen was zeit empfindung zeit
erfahrung haben kann was ich auf was
sich erinnernd bezieht was die zeit im
sinne der wie es eben augustinus sagte
erwartung wahrnimmt und die zeit im
sinne der erinnerung letztendlich also
wo wir ein iks ansetzen
durch das im modus des bewusstseins die
zeit hindurch strömt und so was können
wir eben bei so einer ursuppe einfach
nicht annehmen also wir hätten objektiv
genau dieselben zeitlichen maße wir
könnten sagen natürlich das jetzt eben
dieses das sei jetzt dieses
geschichtliche oder subjekt subjektive
modell die zeit beträge hier sind genau
gleich groß genau gleich große also
nicht so dass jetzt wird sich die eine
zeile wir relative das jetzt drei
minuten nur zwei minuten und bei der
anderen zu die zeit beträge sind genau
dieselben aber wie wir eben über die
zeit reden wie wir zeitempfinden oder
dass wir überhaupt zeit empfinden dass
wir von so was wie gegenwärtig und
zukünftig aufgeht ausgehen was sich
immer wieder nicht gemessen was du jetzt
durchläuft das haben wir in diesen
ursachen modell eben nicht da gibt es
kein zurück gibt derzeit erfahren und
beim john mccain hat auf dem wir noch
kommen wird
ganz am ende der spricht eben von zwei
reihen der zeit war eine arai derzeit
von einer bäckerei derzeit eine reihe
die ist abhängig von so einem zug der
zeit empfindungen wo es eben vergangenes
gegen wir diese zukünftiges gibt und ein
modell das ist das modell da gibt es
eben nur früher oder später
da gibt es nur zeit beträge und
existiert uns ein subjekt was
irgendwelche zukunft erfahrungen oder
vergangenheit erfahren hat nicht das ist
eine objektivierung des
ja und
er hat für uns
ja eben also er löst dieses problem
ebenso dass es auf das subjekt bezieht
sie haben insofern 1 1 status als wir
ins geben und einem gewissen motors dazu
verhalten können also sie sind dadurch
dass sie subjektiv verhandelt werden
dass wir subjektive bezüge herrscht sie
sind letztendlich schon durchaus auch
das ist sehr subjektiv aber eben nicht
so subjektiv wie man es auch drehen
könnte das ist jetzt nur ein konstrukt
ist sie werden nur so präsent zu und
logisch virulent insofern sie sich als
modi der subjektivität erschließen
lassen in verschiedenen zugangsweisen
und die einheit dieser zugangsweisen
dass wir uns eben nach vorne beziehen
können auf das was eigentlich noch nicht
ist und auf das was nicht mehr ist diese
einheit die leiste das subjekt das
objekt das objekt was eben diese drei
vermögen der erwartung der anschauung
das ist dann die selbstbezüglichkeit und
der erinnerung hat da kommen da während
man sich alle drei dimensionen oder
stadien oder ekstasen derzeit auf ein
zentrum bezogen
das als die einheit dieser drei ekstasen
durch das objekt geleistet aber auf die
recht subjektive weise stimmt ja
jetzt hatten sich der kommilitone vorne
gemeldet ich wollte nur sagen
entsprechend schwierig für ihn weil dann
der bedenken ist dass das durch die tour
so viele unterschiedliche vorstellungen
jahre alt marl ohne geschäft existiert
die wahrnehmung
dass ich meine selbst wenn des menschen
und gott existiert eben nicht in der
zeit das ist ein wichtiger punkt gott
existiert wie wir gesagt außerhalb der
zeit unserer deswegen weil er der grund
derzeit überhaupt ist von der
christlichen schöpfung aus durchaus auch
wir müssen noch genauer schauen wie
viele es wirklich von seinem
christlichen hintergrund jetzt notwendig
beeinflusst ist wenn wir jetzt gleich
noch kurz auf august auf aristoteles
eingehen
also ich finde dass da noch eine meldung
[Musik]
nun kommt sehr gute frage wie sehen es
die anderen kommilitonen kommilitonen
spuren ja selbstbewusstsein bewusstsein
für mich frage dass er sagt das ist kann
jedoch ein tier sein oder auch
gegenstand sein wird als erinnerung wäre
ja irgendwie so was er in dieser debatte
so ein schwaches abbild dass man also
wie der kommilitonen sei keine spur hat
es ist noch ein schwaches abbild in
unserem geist
es wird etwas aufbewahrt wir machen so
eine schwache kopie so könnte man sich
das vorstellen
das ist jetzt die frage nach der
philosophie des geistes wir hatten mal
was ist war mal was und das war was war
hinterlässt eine spur in uns das zieht
vorbei aber es im schwachen sinne
interesses und abbild in uns in unserem
gedächtnis in unserer erinnerung genau
ganz genau gegenwärtige spuren so könnte
man sich das vielleicht vorstellen guter
punkt ja also guter punkt also es hängt
davon wie es also ob man zeitempfinden
hat hängt wesentlich davon ab ob man
erinnerungen hat und das hat amtieren
natürlich auch also jetzt vielleicht
also es ist es ist so man weiß in der
neueren affen forschung oder
primatenforschung dass es ziemlich ganz
selten bei lebewesen ist dass sie
zukunfts bewusstsein haben oder
zukünftige ängste auch haben dass man
ängste überhaupt empfinden kann hängt
damit zusammen dass man sich ein begriff
eine vorstellung von der zukunft machen
kann etwas antizipieren kann und das ist
im tierreich ganz ganz so extrem selten
eigentlich nur beim menschen möglich
dass man einen solchen zukünftigen
zeitbegriff hat in der vergangenheit
sieht es anders aus mit der mit der
erinnerung ja aber deswegen haben tiere
auch nicht in dieser form ängste limes
menschen haben können ja eine vorrecht
bestimmten dass sich tiere fürchten von
bestimmten dingen aber dass die
zukunftsangst entwickeln der welt angst
und sowas wie es dann auch heiliger
sagen wird das hängt eben davon ab dass
sie nicht ein solches zukunfts
bewusstsein haben wir hier aber im sinne
der vergangenheit denke ich schon dass
sich tiere an etwas erinnern können und
daraus dann eben auch schlüsse ziehen
können im begrenzten maße zum beispiel
bei krähen oder so nahe bei sehr
intelligenten tieren ist es möglich aber
auf ihre frage um ein solches
zeitverständnis haben wie augustinus
ansetzt müssen wir über eine extrem ist
ausgebildete form von subjektivität
fügen wir müssen selbstbewusstsein haben
und das ist vielleicht in ansätzen bei
höheren primaten der fall
aber er hat einen sehr starken zur
qualitäts begriff also eine sehr hohe
form von reflexivität und das haben wir
eigentlich nur bei menschen also zeit
bewusst sein denke ich ist durchaus
würde ich jetzt mal prima fahrzeug sagen
nicht nur eine sache von alles oder
nichts sondern wir können es in geraden
haben ja also wir können uns in gewissen
maßen tiere vorstellen denkt das ist
plausibel
die zeit bewusstsein haben sie haben
eine gewisse erinnerung an vergangen ist
deswegen würde ich sagen kann man da so
ein graduell ist modell ansätzen ist
nicht eine frage von alles oder nichts
würde ich sagen es hängt davon ab wie
hoch die reflexivität der subjektivität
ist die in der zeit existiert so würde
ich das mal so reflektierte das subjekt
ist was ich derzeit befindet um so mehr
zeit bewusstsein hat ist und da können
wir uns durchaus tierarten vorstellen
die eben rudimentäre form von
subjektivität haben und dementsprechend
auch ein rudimentäres zeit verhältnissen
zeit verstehen
haben zum beispiel affen menschenaffen
die sich erinnern an gewisse personen
die sich erinnern an bestimmte
situationen natürlich haben die zeit
bewusst sein
vor allem eben auf die vergangenheit
gerichtet und nicht so sehr auf die
zukunft ich würde sagen es geht hand in
hand mit der reflexivität mit der
komplexität der subjektivität die da in
der zeit existiert
deswegen würde ich jetzt vielleicht
modifizieren zu augustinus sind gratis
tisches modell von zeit bewusstsein
vorschlagen was eben analog ist zum
graduell ist ischen modell von
subjektivität
es gibt einfach stärker und schwächer
ausgeprägte form von subjektivität
individuen die eine höhere form eine
stärkere selbst reflexivität haben und
individuum ihre schwäche reform haben
ich würde nicht sagen dass eine sache
von alles oder nichts ist und deswegen
würde ich tiere prinzipiell auch mit
einbeziehen als subjektive zeitfahren
ist vielleicht dass die von ihren gesagt
haben könnte man jetzt sagen bei uns
gilt ein zu wichtiges zeichen
eine subjektive betrachtung von zeit
heute in der fixpunkt das bewusstsein
oder bei august bares total ist wie wir
gleich genau bewusst sein
genau es gibt eben nicht dieses ding wo
die zeit durchzieht das oder das was in
der zeit reitet auf derzeit leitet das
gibt es eben nicht bei aristoteles und
bei newton und der ganzen in modernen
physik das gibt es nicht dieses
einfallstor dieses eben subjekt durch
das die zeit durchläuft das ist eine
entität wo die moderne physik oder halt
auch die klassische sagt die brauchen
wir nicht die ist nur unnötiger ballast
wir brauchen hier objektive zeit
verhältnisse und da brauchen wir nicht
so ein subjekt wo die zeit durchläuft es
wird gestrichen
wir haben nur zeitpunkt und können von
diesen zeitpunkten ganz objektiv reden
sie waren früher oder später
und das ist dann bei mctaggart eben eine
besondere form von 23 und 3 und eine
weite von ist eben die reihe wo die zeit
durch das durchläuft oder wo das objekt
in der zeit bereitet wo daneben
vergangenheit und gegenwart gegenwart im
sinne dieses subjektiven modus
thematisch werden und dann gibt es eine
23 wo das eben überhaupt keine rolle
spielt und da kommt dann meckert noch
taufen wir sehen diese zeitreihen jetzt
schon bei augustinus schon vor geprägte
redet eigentlich nur von dieser ein
zeitreihe nämlich gutes objekt derzeit
erfahrung immer so ein fixpunkt ist gut
ja gut also kannte würde eine ganz
spannende sache unternehmen bekannt
würde versuchen sondern synthese aus
diese arbeit zu machen also diese reihe
die dieses subjekt braucht wo derzeit
durchläuft und dieses dieses objekt iwis
tische zeit modell wo praktisch zeit
bewusst seien keine rolle spielt kann
würde sagen das subjekt das trans
zentrales objekt ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit von zeit überhaupt also da
würde dann diese zweite reihe hier da
diese erste hier die würde sich
sozusagen erst ergeben durch ein subjekt
das subjekt wäre die bedingungen der
möglichkeit
überhaupt einer selbst new chain janisch
verstanden zeit eine objektiv ist es
verstanden zeigt also selbst eine
objektive zeit würde kann sagen wer also
noch viel radikaler als augoustinos eine
objektive zeit wo es früher oder später
geben kann
die ist nur möglich weil es ein subjekt
gibt ein trans zentrales system also das
ist noch mal eine spur radikaler als
augustinus aber wir kommen da noch traum
ja
das war der punkt der kommilitonen bin
ich auch sehr gut finde oder wollte sie
meistens nur auf die vergangenheit
bezogen
und natürlich auch
aber mein verhalten der reifen
zudem hat wurde
es sind einfach verhältnisse erwartungs
verhältnis sind immer vom subjekt
ausgehend seien gewissermaßen nach vorne
gerichtet aber auch eben rückwirkend
dass man enttäuscht wird dass man
bestätigt wird in der erwartung
ich erwarte etwas und es tritt dann
entweder so ein dann bin ich dadurch
bestätigt oder es tritt nicht ein habe
ich verhalten genau es geht sogar denn
es nicht kann nur dann bestätigt oder
enttäuscht werden wenn es gegenwärtig
ist das ist richtig aber dennoch würde
ich sagen also geht von mir ein pfeil
aus und er kommen dann auch wieder
zurück als ich verhalte mich dann zu dem
zukünftigen wenn es gegenwärtig geworden
ist eben im modus der bestätigung oder
modus der enttäuschung
es ist ein bisschen schwierig so kann
man es auch sei es ein wechsel
verhältnissen also ich erwarte etwas und
ich werde dann enttäuscht oder bestätigt
das ist dieser fall so würde ich sagen
und dann kann ich sagen das was gekommen
ist bestätigt enttäuscht mich aber
stetig und enttäuschung sind nur
insofern möglich als ich sie in die
zukunft richten
und als die zukunft auf mich zukommt
sie sehen dagegen war das ist richtig
aber sie sind gekommen und sie sind nur
insofern gegenwärtig als sie zukünftig
waren also ist es da immer noch dieser
modus der zukünftig kite präsent weil es
eben auf mich im sinne des stetigen
soder enttäuschend
ich kann nichts vergangenes enttäuschen
letztendlich bestätigen vielleicht aber
vergangenes kann mich enttäuschen
ich habe keine erwartungen gegenüber der
vergangenheit keine antizipation
gegenüber vergangenheit also ich denke
man kann das ganz schematisch so machen
und jetzt will ich aber muss ich leider
weiter ich möchte nämlich jetzt noch
hier kurz zu augoustinos aristoteles
kommen in den letzten fünf minuten
das ist didaktisch nicht sonderlich
geschickt aber ich muss das noch machen
und wir werden natürlich auch einen
nächsten sitzung wieder ein bisschen
darauf zu sprechen kommt also wir haben
hier ein paar fragen hierbei aristotle
ist wie verhalten sich zahl und zeit
nach aristoteles zueinander wie
verhalten sich zeit und bewegung
zueinander und inwiefern existiert die
zeit und ich kann schon mal voraus sagen
dass bei aristoteles eben diese
subjektivität diese six durch das die
zeit hindurch läuft nicht existieren
interessiert ihn nicht
ihn interessiert ihr basieren zeitpunkt
in einer gewissen weise schon aber nicht
im sinne des subjekts sondern vom jetzt
er spricht vom jetzt vom nun griechische
mühe vom nun dass genau wieder deutsch
begriff und jetzt ist lese dass man als
jedenfalls subjektivität spielt nicht so
eine große rolle für aristoteles und
dann kann man sich eben aber das haben
wir jetzt gerade auch schon diskutiert
die frage stellt wie sieht die zeit
theorien von augustinus mit derjenigen
von aristoteles zueinander verhalten
also sagte folgendes zunächst ist es von
vorteil hier über also über die zeit und
griechisch ist dass perry como also
chronos ist die zeit über die zeit perry
como zweifelsfragen anzustellen
auch mittels äußerlich herbei
gezogene überlegung nämlich ob sie zu
sein denn das ist richtig
sie kennen alle die ornithologie das ist
die lehre vom seien bis zum boden gehört
oder zum nicht sein im gehört zum meer
heißt nicht da die nichts also dann ist
danach zu fragen was denn ihr wirkliches
wesen ist das wesen ist die physis für
das heißt auch die natur also die natur
einer sache das ist eben ihre natur das
ist ihr wesen also hier sind ganz
ähnliche fragen erst mal im raum stehend
wie bei augustinus nämlich auch die nach
dem motto logischen status der zeit
dann würde ich nicht sagen er hat für
den begriff des sein denn das telefon
für das ist ihr die wesens bestimmung
der begriff die definition
ja aber ich habe im text nachgeschaut
also es ist es ist die physis geführt
es gibt noch die usa das ist die wesen
haid aber sie haben ja den text von mir
bekommen und da können sie immer links
und rechts vergleichen da steht eben
fürs ist ein wirkliches wesen ihre natur
man könnte vielleicht also müsste es so
sagen die physis ist dann auch immer das
was definiert was definiert werden kann
aber so wie wir im deutschen sagen was
ist denn die natur dieser sache was ist
denn das wesen dieses machen
platon würde vielleicht sagen sie ja
aber aristoteles sagt es ist also hier
geht es darum dass wie bei augustinus
zunächst mal einfach die frage gestellt
wird ja wie ich ihn und theologischen
status hatten die zeit immer vor dem
hintergrund dass es gegenwärtiges
zukünftiges und vergangenes gibt und
jetzt sagte weiter folgendes dass sie
nun also entweder überhaupt nicht
möglich ist oder nur unter anstrengungen
und auf dunkle weise das möchte man aus
folgenden tatbeständen vermuten dass
eine teilstück von ihr von der zeit von
chronos ist darüber gegangen und ist
insoweit nicht mehr die vergangenheit
das andere steht noch bevor
und ist insoweit noch nicht aus
aus diesen stücken besteht sowohl die
ganze unendliche wie auch die jeweils
genommene zeit was nun aus nicht sein
damit zusammengesetzt ist von dem
scheint es doch wohl möglich zu sein
das ist ein teil haben
da hat sich augustinus bestimmt auf
aristoteles bezogen sie kennen noch
diese eine stelle wo er sagt wir können
jetzt so ein zeitpunkt herausziehen und
dann sehen wir aber wenn er ausgedehnt
ist dann erstreckt dass ich wieder ein
gegenwärtiges und zukünftiges und alles
was gegenwärtig ist ist nicht etwas
zukünftiges ist nicht alles was
vergangenes ist nichts also ist es doch
eigentlich nicht also wir haben jetzt
endlich genau dasselbe dilemma wie bei
augustinus oder augustinus korrekt
gesagt hat genau dasselbe dilemma wie
schon aristoteles vor ihm hatte außerdem
von jedem teil waren ding falls es ist
müssen solange es ist entweder alle
seine teiles sein oder auch einige von
derzeit dagegen sehen die ein teile
schon vor über die anderen stehen noch
bevor
es ist keiner und das wo sie doch
teilbar ist das jetzt aber ist nicht
teil der time ist das ganze aus und das
ganze muss aus den teilen bestehen
zurzeit besteht aber ganz offensichtlich
nicht aus den letzten und griechisch
heißt das nun wie das deutsche wort nun
genau dieselbe wurzel finde ich ganz
lustig dass er als im plural von diesem
letzten spricht jetzt zeitpunkten was
ganz interessant also das ist nicht teil
sondern und da kommt jetzt wieder so
eine gewisse im schwachen sinne
subjektive dimensionen spiel das nun
dass jetzt das nun ist dasjenige wo sich
das subjekt eben derzeit erfahrung
befindet
dass das jetzt überhaupt wichtig wird in
seiner physikalischen reihe spielt das
jetzt nicht so eine große rolle
da spielt derzeit punkte rolle den ich
einst setzte die formel täglich so und
so viel sekunden dann setzt sich einfach
also hier kommt im schwachen szene schon
subjektivität ins spiel
jetzt lese ich das nächste nach vorn
dann müssen aber auch aufhören weiter
was das jetzt an geht welches
augenscheinlich vergangenes und
zukünftiges trend so ist nicht gleich zu
sehen ob es die ganze zeit hindurch
immer ein und dasselbe bleibt oder ob es
immer wieder ein anderes wird das ist
genau die frage die wir uns bei
akustischen gestellt hatten
das subjekt das gegenwärtige ob das in
der zeit voraus rennt oder ob es durch
fließt
gut also nicht ganz genau das geht so
ein bisschen diese richtung als ob wir
uns in der zeit immer weiter voran
schieben oder ob wir konstant bleiben
das meinte damit dieses konstante jetzt
wo alles in der früh
ja das ist also die spannende frage ich
lese mal zu ende wenn es einerseits
wieder und wieder ein anderes wird kein
teil aber dessen was in der zeit immer
wieder ein anderes ist gleichzeitig mit
anderen sein kann sofern nicht der eine
umfasst der anderen fasst wird sowie ein
kleinerer zeitabschnitt von einem
größeren eingeschlossen wird und wenn
was jetzt nicht ist früher aber war
notwendig um irgendwann einmal zu grunde
gegangen sein muss dann können auch die
jetzt nicht gleichzeitig im verhältnis
zueinander sein es muss jeder frühere
untergegangen sein genau während der
eigenen dauer kann es nicht zugrunde
gang sein weil es da noch nicht war aber
zur zeit eines anderen jetzt kann das
frühere jetzt auch nicht untergegangen
sein
es soll dabei als unmöglich
vorausgesetzt sein dass die jetzt
miteinander zusammenhängen wehren sowie
das ja auch im verhältnis von punkt zu
punkt
wenn es nun also in dem der einer sich
anschließenden nicht zugrunde gegangen
ist sondern erst einem weiteren dann
wäre es ja noch in den dazwischen
liegenden letzten oder unendlich viele
sind vorhanden und so gleichzeitig mit
ihnen das kann nicht sein
also hier haben wir jetzt dieses problem
bei aristoteles wie sich das jetzt
verstehen lässt ist das jetzt ein
zeitpunkt existiert er es ausgedehnt
existiert es überhaupt wie verhält es
sich zu anderen zeitpunkten in diesem
zeitlichen container und ich kann schon
vorausblickend sagen dass aristoteles
und das klang her auch schon an also von
sonnen punkt sprach dass er oder von dem
kontinuum sprach dass er die zeit in
ganz starker analogie zur zahl
betrachten wird also das zeit- und zahl
dass es so wie in diesen zahlen strahl
gibt unendlich vielen kleineren zahlen
seinerzeit an zahlen kommentieren so
gibt es für ihn eben auch ein zeitkonto
entscheidend ist aber für ihn dass er
eben die zeit vom raum ableitet er macht
die zeit vom rauen abhängig und nicht
den raum von der zeit und damit steht er
in einer anderen anderen verhältnis als
die moderne physik ist sieht es nämlich
anders aber das wollen wir jedenfalls
noch im hinterkopf haben wir wollen
jetzt also mal hier in der nächsten
sitzung noch ein bisschen aristoteles
machen und dann immer auf fragen wie er
sich zu einem augustinus verhält dann
bis zur nächsten